in terms of influencing us and cs go he
certainly dictated the way the op was
played he was on a significantly worse
team he was on a team that couldn't
actually win big titles
or if they could it would have been by
the narrowest margin and he had to do
those god-like plays
to even give him a chance to win every
opera i see and like online that tries
to replicate that
it can't do it and there's a reason for
that
pushes from titan have been called and
found out but there's kenny estwick too
and a third as well
i'm always worried when i see kenny s
kind of frowning while he's playing you
know you want kenny has to be smiling
anything could happen if kenny was alive
and he had an awp that's how good he was
does get planted still okay stuck in the
site finding more that's brilliant and
kenny s again up close oh my goodness
kenny s
this guy is absolutely insane kenny
shrub
didn't have your average ascent to
greatness but the french prodigy who
grew up in the world of counter-strike
has become synonymous with the game's
tradition of highlight plays
and even the mighty off itself this is
the story
of kenny s what are you doing
you've got to be kidding at the clutch
oh my god
born in france in 1995 it's not an
exaggeration to say that kenny grew
up in counter-strike he would try the
game for the first time at the age of
six
because his older brother cyril was
already playing when cyril was away at
school
kenny would get some time on the
computer and though counter-strike was
his refuge from family issues
what he found in it was longer-lived
[Music]
kenny would return from school and play
the game late into the evening
drawing concern from his mother but
those late nights allowed kenny to make
his way
into france's competitive counter-strike
scene and not only had kenny found a
foothold in the game
he had discovered his niche in it as
well the awp
or op has been an important part of
competitive counter-strike from the very
beginning
the high-powered sniper rifle offers a
one-shot kill with a hit to the head or
chest
but is offset by a slow rate of fire and
a considerable monetary investment
despite the weapon's loud signature
report
it is a precision weapon harnessed by
the sniper's reflexes to bring
instant ruin to the opposition the young
kenny showed affinity for the weapon
and while he has said that it's hard to
pinpoint the exact moment that he
decided
to take on the sniper role he says he
feels that the weapon
chose him working his way up through the
french scene
kenny met a player called bless and
began playing on a community mumble
server
called the wall which is where his
career would begin in earnest with most
of his early matches being played
online kenny's prowess drew attention
from some on the server
most players don't get the opportunity
to start off with one of their region's
best teams
but kenny did in 2011 he was traveling
with vari games a french counter-strike
source roster that fielded the likes of
existence
nbk rpk and apex
but kenny's debut at offline events was
anything but smooth
while he was able to prove that he
wasn't cheating the pressure of the
later rounds got to him
a pattern that would repeat itself later
in his career
i think a lot of it has to do with his
play style um certain teams don't
necessarily favor him to be aggressive
as he is he kind of had to prove himself
in that regard
um but i i mean you talk about success
coming through source someone he was a
young player it's hard to get a chance
when you're that young
while very games would continue without
kenny he quickly found a spot on team
extensive and although he hadn't made
the cut with vg
he didn't view the experience negatively
considering the competition he had faced
but five months later kenny would
finally get his chance to join the very
game's
starting roster following mk's removal
um
kenny and the team attended both
insomnia 45
and 46 for cs source taking home the
first place prize at both events
but a challenge loomed on the horizon
the impending release of counter-strike
global offensive
source had been the game that kenny had
built his young career in
and the move to global offensive was
anything but easy
if you look at the game closely first
the game looks like construct source the
recoil the
graphics everything looks like source
but when you look at the gameplay
are the tactics and everything like that
you can really see that the game is more
for 1.6
the game's early reception was mixed and
for competitive players from both source
and cs 1.6 it felt different and there
was a lot to learn
and not a lot of time to learn
more
[Music]
almost immediately after global
offensive's release the team headed to
dreamhack valencia 2012.
once he got to land though kenny found
his groove making some great plays with
the ops newest incarnation
fairy games went for this push into
upper there that just didn't quite work
out bikinis
oh is this gonna make a huge higher
fit flaring in a bad spot he is
completely blind trying to hang out on
ladder shops oh he actually gets it
and now tony can he has a remaining huge
headshot together oh my god what's going
on in this little frenchman's head
but on the other hand an op isn't
exactly the weapon you want in a one
versus one kenny's is working into the
right angle and so is the flare they're
about to run directly into each other
still it wasn't enough to take first
place very games
considered by many to be the strongest
source team in the world at that time
was upended by ninjas and pajamas who
had been previously playing cs 1.6
this could be it for barry games as
they're working their way into the bomb
site trying to split both ways but
they're being contended very well
they're being pushed back
in two white holes smith's steel series
i'm sorry exists on the kennedys there
it is ladies and gentlemen
a new rivalry was born from the
convergence of both scenes
in cs go and vg's inability to beat nip
over the following months would become a
source of frustration for the team
very games did eventually start to catch
up to nip
but a victory against them remained a
loose position
will win it for n.i.p gaming but for
kenny
the rivalry was put on hold in the wake
of the esea
season 13 lan finals a disappointing
third place finish
after a loss to quantic gaming meant
that it wasn't vg
playing nip in the finals
days after being kicked the young opera
was recruited by
ldlc the team had been formed from the
ashes of team extensive's previous
roster
so kenny was familiar with many of his
new teammates while kenny's time with
ldlc
would end up being short it was here
that he would finally conquer one of his
biggest demons
n.i.p
led to some more troubles he and the
team were upset by
epsilon at dreamhack summer 2013.
it marked another disappointing third
place exit for kenny
cracks were beginning to form within the
squad and soon after
kenny and apex were released from ldlc
following a brief stint with we got game
kenny would eventually join up with
recursive prior to dreamhack winter
his former teammate apex approached him
asking if there was an opening on the
roster
kenny didn't want to change a player
before the tournament offering instead
to rebuild ldlc
after the event but kenny would
ultimately be left out of that roster
and posted an angry statement that
criticized both apex
and the other team members that had
turned their backs on him it was a
moment where kenny's emotions got the
better of him
and one that he would later regret we
still see a camera like his hands are
shaking at times like
he has that that really like raw
adrenaline sort of emotion that goes
with him and you can
certainly see him being frustrated at
times and then
i'd say i'd say more frequently see him
frustrated and stressed than you do
happy
kenny would spend the next month and a
half with clan mystic
before being asked to join titan
given the prior incidents with kenny it
was an important step to getting his
career back on track
pretty much on the a site pnx not going
to give it up without a fight and it's
going to come down to kenny s with the
awp 1v3 we can see where he's looking
now just gets the shot barely on msl
finds the second one can he ask with the
no scope
titan had qualified for esl one cologne
2014
but despite being considered a strong
team they failed to make it out of
groups
after running into team dignitas and
cloud9
after cologne the team was swept up into
the first french shuffle in late 2014.
once the dust had settled in september
kenny would be joined by
existence cali apex and maniac on titan
following a number of second place
finishes titan would eventually triumph
at the dreamhack invitational too
entries and to which site they want to
converge on kenny s is just having a
field day but as 2014 drew to a close
the team would receive bad news callie
was banned for cheating
on november 20th which both hurt the
team in the immediate sense
and also prevented them from playing at
dreamhack winter 2014
which meant that kenny would have to
wait for another chance at proving
himself
on the big stage for a team that had
been developing and felt ready to take
the event
the setback to both their play and
mental state was immense
cali's replacement would eventually be
rpk who came out of retirement to join
the squad
in late december as 2015 began the team
qualified for the next major
esl one katowice but again they failed
to get out of groups and they were
eliminated by penta
more bad news came weeks later as valve
released a patch to cs go
that substantially changed how the op
worked
it's not as fluid as it was it's not as
quick the velocity is not there
and this immediately for the pro scene
is a massive nerf
the change drastically altered the way
that operas had to deal with specific
angles in the game
angles that had existed in some form
within cs 1.6
and source it wasn't it didn't have the
skill suddenly it was that it's it's
muscle memory and it's force of habit
and you have to really dial back and
relearn it and i think
because he was the one that took
advantage of that movement mechanic so
much it took him a little bit longer to
do so
because it just felt like he got gutted
right when he was coming into his prime
when he could have been god
and just taken over everything the game
was changed and then i think that really
impacted his confidence
the drastic change coupled with kenny's
affinity for the op
even inspired a joke video about what it
was like to play against titan
post nerf complete with a viking funeral
for the rifle the actual effect on kenny
though
was no laughing matter as titan
continued to slump into 2015. the
immediate
result was certainly kenny a little bit
guardian but
certainly kenny was hurt the most as i
talked about he was someone who could
play
very close he could move very quickly
with the op he could hit no scopes he
was constantly quick peeking and quick
scoping
that movement mechanic was taken out
quite significantly titan managed
top four placements at esl pro league
one
esea season 18 gfinity spring masters 2
and dreamhack summer 2015 and despite
his struggles
kenny still produced the incredible
moments he was known for
and there's the peak kenny takes out
guardian gets the follow-up as well and
now the third kill goes for the no-scope
might get it and yes he will
oh man god like i mean yes okay his team
were set up around
him but it didn't matter if kenny was in
a 1v3
uh you'd almost take positive odds for
him to come out you know and just get
that 1v3 and clutch it
he was so scary to the point where the
dominant
the most dominant team in cs go history
fnatic with olofmeister and everybody
right
they were like we don't like playing
against kenny kenny makes me scared
all of a sudden i don't know what to do
when i'm playing against kenny because
if i peek even a pixel i could be there
just knowing that they're close as well
it's going gonna be the old battle again
jw versus kenny and kenny comes out on
top
jw was one pixel away with that shot and
look at titan here comes the speed right
into the a bomb side they're not missing
a step
kenny with a second shot but the results
were not what fans expected from such a
high profile roster
the slump brought consequences and when
the second french shuffle completed in
july 2015
kenny was once again on the move heading
to team envious with apex
yet again he and shocks had switched
teams both
titan and envy had been underperforming
before the swap
but afterwards was a different story
envy went on to win
iem gamescom against danish upstart's
team solomid work with the bomb plans
can take five seconds alone he's gonna
go for it behind the fountain carrick is
going to charge him down
he's going to miss quite a few pistol
shots kenny yes he want to kill
kerrigan should not have but then he
gets the second kds
clutches around not only was it a win
but it was a decisive one
although it wasn't a major the event was
a proving ground for the newly formed
roster
weeks later the team was facing down
their first major appearance at esl one
cologne 2015.
envyus would emerge from group b as the
top team
but they weren't satisfied with just
that in the quarterfinals
envy cut through na'vi is he going to
try and go huge here
can he ends on site straight in his face
doesn't hit the nose go
doesn't hit the pistol can he ask
would you believe it
then they cast aside tsm in the
semifinals
envy they're punishing tsm capri goes
down
and it all comes down to sipnicks here
1v4 he's got 15 seconds and can denies
it to envy they make their grand finals
here
in cologne a surging fanatic awaited
them in the grand finals
and kenny was one best of three series
away from winning his first major but
fanatics crims
had other plans they heard the plan
happy tried to go aggressive tried to
rattle the shots through but
as you saw mbk he's going full on he's
just ready to pounce on through and why
would they slow down there's the flash
that's going to catch crims out they're
going to push on through
nbk guess what but crips with a spray
down he can't sit down the triple
the fnatic are not done yet that was the
turning point
a round that should have been an easy
win instead it collapsed in such
spectacular fashion
that the victory seemed impossible it's
gonna require
a miracle and nothing less for happy to
make it out i don't think there's
any chance flusher looking to end this
it's gonna be a third title for fnatic
they win
a third major championship in global
offensive
taking second should still have been an
encouraging result
but it wasn't for kenny kennedy must be
devastated right now
he had probably the worst game
of his career on that cobblestone game
despite their disappointment kenny and
envious would return with a vengeance
at dreamhack open london a few weeks
later taking first place after beating
team solomid in the grand finals with
renewed confidence
the team set their sights on the next
valve major dreamhack cluj-napoca
the event would see envy top their group
and cast aside fnatic in the bracket
stage
but an absolute nail-biter against g2
esports in the semi-finals
nearly dashed their championship hopes
with envy down
one map after dropping dust 2 g2 managed
to force
overtime on inferno in the middle of the
second overtime
envy were down three rounds and as kenny
remembers it
the team was not communicating properly
but against the odds
and in defiance of another failed major
run they won the map
in the third overtime and rode that
momentum through the series four versus
four now as the whole
ct side is rotating but happy is
annihilating the entire economy
three-man spray down mouth one all day
three heads for him
only fox remains now versus four players
he'll take
one and that's going to be that envy
will take it in one of the most
difficult victories i have ever seen
in town to strike in the grand finals
they'd face a familiar adversary
na'vi there they won train navi's map
in a close game but it was on kabul
where they dominated
and now it's the one versus one or first
solve candy versus guardian and this
could be
a huge round for either player uncanny
he steals it away it doesn't even matter
there's the shot and the money for navi
is gonna be reset but nbk removes deuce
and it's not looking good
oh and a second head show there flamie
gonna be going hiroshima and there it
[Applause]
title in is for three of these players
the first to penny
and any case what a victory just under
four years
since his first land appearance kenny a
player that
many had already described as the
world's best opera had finally
unbeknownst to them at the time
cluj-napoca was also the highest
competitive point
that this incarnation of the roster
would ever reach
after more inconsistent results the team
dropped kioshima
and brought in devil the move did little
to improve the team's fortunes
and their first couple of land
performances were poor
you have to have like that complete and
utter arrogance right you have to know
without a shadow of a doubt that you are
the best person on that server and that
whatever your will is it will happen
right
there's no goddamn way that he's gonna
do this he's got no health calls gonna
go for it he gets the shot
can you want to enjoy you've gotta be
kidding at the clutch
oh my god and once you lose that sense
of invincibility that arrogance knowing
it
it's so hard to get it back in a game
like that it's so hard to get it back
and i think kenny was kind of cast out
into the wild for for a while there
then the unthinkable happened after
years of missing each other the latest
front shuffle saw the creation of a g2
team
that for the first time included both
kenny s
and shocks dubbed by some to be the
french super team
the roster also fielded nbk apex
and body and in his quest for further
glory with g2
kenny has reminded everyone why he
should be feared
and indeed one is kenny with a simply
rude peek into season on top of mustang
kenny s in heaven
kenny s with the double kill and the
triple for the round and the qual
kenny first at the back he finds the
shot but he's being pressured up close
he needs shocks to support him he's
watching for a flight for what squawk
oh my god kenny gets an incredible kill
against sixer
are going to rely on kenny to deal with
the players from long able to take down
one there's more where that came from
though but for kenny
it is simply too easy meaning happy will
just about survive
still on six hp gonna go for the push
gets the no scope on to scream
that's ridiculous leaving happy he's
just gonna go straight for the defuse
kenny getting the timing and he will
even get the kill at the end wonderful
stuff from kenny
middle but it's quickly dealt with and
now
it's just a cleanup for g2 as they will
take that lead back
there he is kenny asked for the 4k which
is going directly
yes kenny has grown up in cs and he's
got plenty of career ahead of him and
regardless of what comes next
he has emerged through a battle against
his own emotional nature
as truly one of the best to ever pick up
the awk
teams changed completely changed how
they played the game just because of
one player because of kenny that's how
scarily good he was thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this
be sure to hit the subscribe button